you are listening to the hot breath
podcast I am your host comedian Joel
Byers and welcome to your weekly guide
to comedy mastery with Carlos Miller
lots changed we are all the way out here
man you got a house now microphone hang
a bigger plate of [ __ ] and hold the mic
Oh were you planning on playing a video
game man doing a podcast it's all good
did I just know that is rude okay you
did not ruin my day bro my days are not
ruin upon is that a word I just made a
word oh we're already starting he just
made a word word man yes I guessing
what's going on dude thanks for thanks
for doing this man thank you so much
yeah it's been a minute literally last
time well there wasn't a TV on last time
I'm turning it off but we were in a dark
apartment with two strippers yeah in my
mine
you called it your Rick James moment no
there were there were actual strippers
yeah you probably only remember not
definitely remember I was every day
I just went to Kuwait and I've renamed
the base Rick James Air Force Base oh
you're still in your Rick James game
there will be multiple Rick James
tributes throughout my life what is it
about Rick James you like so much [ __ ]
he's a pimp he's a funk legend bro
mm-hmm funk you know what I'm saying the
funk doesn't die so I don't want Rick
James name to die I want to keep it
going
what were you doing out there and Kuwait
telling jokes to some soldiers man doing
just performing on bases around there
well I just did we had one show over
there and I just went in performed over
down on the Air Force Base and [ __ ] that
was pretty dope man they showed us a
little much love that all the soldiers
protecting these freedoms how often do
you do those shows man I just do do
whatever comes up on the calendar man
ain't too specific in
what kind of show it is yeah you know
they came up in the rotation but I'm
always open to doing stuff like that I'm
actually looking forward to doing some
more you know just to see what what else
we have people that want to see it
you got your NPR voice going on right
now yeah you know manipulate the
audience and to believe in me you know I
could listen to it like this is supposed
to be confident okay which is a real
important when you cuz they're used to
hearing you all the way out Wilin out
yeah I'm glad it's a black amount not
weed this time last time yeah you guys
should do after this man yeah I was just
in the room and like bruh I can't even
process right now what do you expect to
happen when you in the room which strip
was man it's gonna be some kind I didn't
know there were gonna be strippers I
just pulled up and there were two chicks
and then we start and you're like how
much should we pay them to get naked and
I was like how much are you paying them
I'm not bad cuz I know you weren't you
were probably already trying to get your
wife and [ __ ] ahead you may hate those
people you wouldn't have met your wife
you see how life was if it wasn't for
those two strippers who the [ __ ] knows
where we would be right now did he be
the first episode would have sucked and
you would have found somebody else yeah
who knows without Carlos Miller I would
not have a wife thank you so much as the
strippers without the strippers yeah the
strippers were there when nobody else
was is a metaphore job no I feel you on
that that was back in episode 16 when
you were episode you all know I'm in the
130s now that's dope man anybody cool
been through this [ __ ] uh Carlos Miller
yeah he's cool Aries Spears oh my god
Roy Wood jr. stop [ __ ] playing I just
had your boy a Chad the producer of 85
South sure what about me
hey man he gave away all the sauce no he
didn't well you know you can give away
the sauce but you know if you don't use
the same cooks he's not gonna taste the
same you can't duplicate yourself
yo that's good yeah how many times have
you said that twice twice all right well
thanks for us getting it on the record
right
he was just talking about how strategic
the 85 South Show is it's not just like
a bunch of people on and then they're
just kind of filming it like every move
along the way is completely intentional
and strategic yeah I think we do a good
job of tying that [ __ ] back together at
the end to make it all make sense yeah
yeah what is what is it like behind the
scenes of that machine from like the
talent perspective behind the scenes is
just like on the scene you know what I'm
saying like we made sure that we give
people to look of the whole aspect of
the show from the studio to the
interview to the lab show so every like
whatever you see on the camera just no
it was a lot more of that going on off
the camera
try to give them a real-life raw look
into how she really is the good the bad
and ugly yeah like you guys filmed the
show you did in Tallahassee where you
about didn't even do it because you
weren't gonna get paid and now you're
doing 800 seats at House of Blues yeah
that's unbelievable but that's just a
game dobro some nights you be at Madison
Square Garden there's some nice you had
a [ __ ] crack them up huckle huckle in
Asheville
Knoxville Kentucky see those places you
just never know where your career may
take you some nice you are starring in
some nice you're coming have you
actually done Madison Square
have you no I know I see it happening
one day I feel like that's just one of
those things you do as an entertainer
but I don't know you know comedy kind of
loses his vibe when you put it in life
in a space that's that big you know I'm
saying oh yeah the intimacy and I
connection yeah it kind of just
screaming into a void yeah but that's a
dope void any of the dope for this it's
a real good problem the hands right
exactly
come out Messer garland you don't reach
the people like you do at huckle hut you
know
oh good that's where you really get your
chops it that's what you really have to
do comedy breath you know every comedian
is not an entertainer
some people are entertainers man you
know what I'm saying you just want to
see them it ain't even just about what
they're saying they're doing is just
being a part of what they're creating
and you've already seen the history they
already made and you're at that point
now I don't want to go see my favorite
comedian at Madison Square Garden if
that makes any sense
come on yeah meeting perspective you
know I mean I would much rather be it a
center stage or you know Fox Theater
somewhere you know that's still a big
size venue that's not sixty thousand 50
thousand Cedars right yeah what's what's
probably the biggest audience you've
been in front of probably about 10,000
what was that for um I was on a Wilin
out - I am there not a lot of shows that
sold out a lot of venues that we did I
think we had about 5,000 here in Atlanta
something like that oh yeah one of those
places I've never heard of that I live
it was like way to [ __ ] have 85
somewhere but it was packed it was
packed to capacity bro like fully slowed
option that's what's so funny about
interviewing you the first time is that
you we're talking about how you didn't
even feel like a main cast member a
Wilin out yet you said don't you still
don't know me this is everyday every cuz
it's like I guess you just have to be
around this [ __ ] to know what they feel
like nobody feels like they're a star on
the show like they're needed okay it's
crazy because we've been on there for a
lot of seasons we've seen a lot of
people come and go and come back in be
banished and yeah all types of [ __ ] you
doesn't never know who that person could
be and you see a lot of people leave the
show and go do bigger [ __ ] be more
successful in theirs as I well it's just
like you know I don't know it's like a
combine or some [ __ ] it is coming it's
almost like an SNL it's kind of like a
who at version of it but better and
chanel is doesn't have the law like it
did you know what I'm saying like
because some of the seems like sometimes
they
they have some great ideas and they
start out great and then the punchline
just getting lost you know but it's a
it's a great I guess if you look at it
like since you got to put that's the
biggest [ __ ] and been around the longest
you gotta put it in a number one place
so is easy to critique it you know right
right what is it what is not but but you
know that's like one of the top shows
that you could be on it's a good median
like I guess there's like a Holy Grail
yeah that's a almost a rite of passage
yeah that's like you really did some you
some elite level [ __ ] to be part of that
so Wilin out is kind of like that but
maybe two stepbrothers I'm sure it's
better Bobby and its SNL is more of very
crafted sketches very rehearsed and very
precise but seems Wilding out it's
almost the exact opposite right this is
what happens when nothing happens except
magic right just the moment you guys can
just create magic in that moment yeah
you know just when it comes to that type
of [ __ ] sometimes it's there to miss is
it a miss with it cuz a lot of people
think that it's a whole lot more that
goes into the actual preparation but
it's really not it's really prepared
right in front of this audience you know
what I'm saying yeah right here if we
burn this [ __ ] is burnt
you ain't change that but the good thing
about it is the way the show moves you
can go from some [ __ ] that maybe the
audience wasn't necessarily feeling like
that but they get it that it's a show so
I just trying to make it work too but
then you go to some [ __ ] you always have
the ones that you know that I crowd
favorites right people came to the show
to see so sometimes they come and they
get a whole they get a show full of
three four new games that they didn't
even know nothing about and that Wow
okay just [ __ ] his way better than what
I was expecting to be here you know me I
thought you're gonna say that a lot of
it just bombs you just know it's not
even it's like that's the part of the
when you're doing it laughs in front of
our audience
sometimes the [ __ ] that bombs is the
most classic moment I've got people on
the show who just refused to make to let
a good joke dad
I'm a wasn't fencing okay I'll use him
as an example his whole [ __ ] is he gonna
try to live a terrible joke bad joke
type like he has those mom's pages he
refuses to bomb and if he has a joke
that's funny to him and it crowd he'll
just keep doing it yeah actually like
the dime jog episode it made the whole
episode about the joke that he did that
did not work crazy
classic um turn a failure into a success
that's what life is all about success
and then like failure is temporary is
only real as long as you accept it but
failure can be a good teacher that's
what I'm saying if you if you get taught
some and you learn how to succeed you
didn't fail you just lacked acknowledge
to succeed at the moment I got damn hot
dropping dropping gotta let that [ __ ]
breathe oh you got that that wisdom is
it is it I think it's because I'm a
little bit older than a lot of people
that's around the circle and I've had
time to really sit back and think about
different aspects of [ __ ]
cuz you know as you get older you're
you're thinking opens up hmm you stop
looking at what they told you or what
you saw because you start to understand
how things work you know I'm saying
everything has a process like with math
you learn the formulas and [ __ ] and then
you start to get results because you can
do every [ __ ] problem if you know the
formula you go homes in you got a
formula yeah yeah I got it for me talk
to him
my formula you give up the whole sauce
for real bro without the chef's though
that's what I'm saying you don't let
nobody interrupt your sauce when you
cooking people have lost the
understanding and value of the word you
cuz at the end of the night you got lay
down by yourself and get up in the
morning look yourself in the mirror you
got to be comfortable with all the
decisions that you make as a human and
stop depending on other people to supply
your happiness once knees thoughts and
desires
it's selfish but is real and when you
start believing in other people that's
how you open yourself up to
disappointments failures heartbreak
depression all that [ __ ] because you
expect a shion's it's the fastest way to
disappointment they'll never let nobody
or nothing disappoint you got to be
comfortable with yourself and know that
you are the key factor that can change
the old situation your life at the end
of the day you are the [ __ ] you are
the key the other DJ Kelly is a major
key yeah yeah but you are the key and
every time you can put some knowledge
and work it and execute it it's just
like you got another one on your on your
loop of keys the more cheese you've got
the less you need from other
[ __ ] if you're looking for
somebody to make you financially happy
and that's all you need you want
somebody because they got money or
whatever you think they can do for you
think of how you gonna feel when you in
that position and and you're not looking
for nobody else to give you what you've
been craving if money is your vice and
you get some money then what you're
gonna have to find another vice because
money ain't gonna be your it's not gonna
be a drug no more cuz you're in excess
of it and it's the thrill is gone like
the old blues song baby came the
thriller is gone it's the thrill of the
chase there's a lot of [ __ ] that we
think that we want until we actually get
it so is that where you are right now
like you've gotten a lot of what you
want and it's not what you thought it
would be no it's not even that it's just
it that's why I can say that I'm happy
with where I am in my success as a
person no however people may see it or
not
I do what makes me happy you know what
I'm saying sometimes it's not a Ferrari
that [ __ ] that's your dream car your
[ __ ] might be right there and your grass
it might be the [ __ ] Mustang that you
wanted in high school you know I'm
saying you always just wanted to GT or
some crazy [ __ ] what whatever it is that
you desire see that's what separates the
people from leg-like greatness and
regular [ __ ] desire the desire
to be yourself you know I'm saying like
you look I'm sent here watching these
[ __ ] build his car you might
look at that [ __ ] I don't want that [ __ ]
but that's somebody's dream car that's
all they ever wanted you know I'm saying
yeah and so that's the type
[ __ ] I'm saying like what is it that
makes you happy it might not even be an
iPhone
it might just you guys got to live for
yourself is basically what I'm saying
your happiness stars in ears with you
you being on the other side it's like
and just this being the follow-up
interview before you were on the rise
and you're still rising this is by no
means like you're still almost you just
getting started and where you're
actually gonna end up but as you've
seemed like you've seen the other side
of the fence now and you've maybe been
in certain rooms with certain people and
you've seen the quote important people
write what it what is that reveal to you
it's just what I finished saying all
that is what you learned in that's what
I don't break your head it's like you
sit or you can be around you meet you
your idols men and they'll sit then you
just seem like damn that's what make you
connect with them the realness
you have the same somebody you're like
when somebody meets somebody said damn
you're so down there it's just a
relatable cool dude it's because it
wasn't trying to pretend to be the
[ __ ] you thought that they were
yeah you know what I'm saying
those are the people who are really the
happiest man and that's what I'm seeing
a lot of people missing out in the world
you know I'm saying a lot of people just
depressed or just chasing [ __ ] that they
think that they're supposed to have to
make people like them and it's sad but
that's how you see a lot of people get
lost in the entertainment field they
start chasing things items objects and
people you gotta have a vision now mmm
so like how did you develop your vision
cuz you've made all in there I actually
went through and did it you know what
I'm saying
I know none of the [ __ ] that I have or
got in my comedy career or entertainment
career was handed to me I actually had
to physically put labour into it mm-hmm
so that's what made me start saying like
okay [ __ ] if I do this and this happens
or this doesn't happen then what you
know I mean cuz you still gotta stay
busy in between these projects that [ __ ]
don't come out when you do it you gotta
stay behind until this [ __ ] come on you
don't want to have the hottest TV show
on on TV and you fell off in the six
months and took four
yeah you got a job and she you a waiter
you got to quit your job so you can go
to your premieres yeah yeah yeah I mean
we we shot a TV show together a little
while ago it was just like a little
pilot
yeah and that was dope too that was my
first time being around comedians of
that caliber where I'm like oh these are
like Broadway part of some classic [ __ ]
now bro we working with Donnell Rawlings
Charlie Marley Murphy did and it was and
then it was like the Mike Epps project
that yeah that's what it was that's what
it was saying and when man it's just
crazy how that heaven I never forgot
about that
and even even the writers were dope
these were dudes who had written on like
South Park and in living color like the
whole project I was like yeah and then
it's one of those things that you know
just never kind of well of course not
without Charlie of course right all
right I mean no general it never really
being there and being a part of it I
know that that [ __ ] was funny is he so
funny and it was it's probably still
could come out hopefully one day
somebody wants to see it you have a lot
of projects that you shoot and then they
just just that's just the game yeah I
think that's just part of the game I
mean it's it's people out there we've
got a hundred pilots so 20 and 30 yeah
it's probably a great shows that they
stopped production made episode I'm not
[ __ ] away right just just because of
the politics of the game it's not always
about the the quality of the show the
people who run it is business people up
top who just sit back and they wanna
they flip channels and they want to be
part of the wave of what's hot and new
right now they just and they lose focus
cuz they have a boss who doesn't give a
[ __ ] about that I just saw that this
show was doing that and that's what the
network is doing yep exactly
it's [ __ ] a lot like like a lot of
talent get lost in there because you
know people don't bite it likes
rejection or feeling like they fail
whether it be your father at night so
you [ __ ] around and lose a job or some
[ __ ] you thought that she was gonna you
know some income that she was expecting
and you don't know how to bounce back
that shaking cause depression and drugs
and all types of [ __ ] BRR
you've been down that road yeah
oh yeah I lost a lot of money doing this
here talk about it bro tell him I lost
about twenty five thousand dollars for
some cruises for some tweets you just
had some tweets they didn't approve of
yeah what were they oh [ __ ] tweet write
some [ __ ] like that I don't give a [ __ ]
man I don't nobody run my [ __ ] and a lot
of these promoters and people who booked
you for shows they think that that gives
them access to your social media with
you the promoter I gotta be the promoter
and the talent [ __ ] you I'm not doing
that [ __ ] unless that's part of the pay
all right I'm gonna post the [ __ ] to let
the people know then follow me to come
[ __ ] with me but I'm not about to
promote this [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] you talking about you the
headliner were you to promote it your
name says promoter right they're not
coming they're coming because you told
them I was coming it's not to see a lot
of times you go do shows in these cities
and then wash it didn't sell out it's
not that they don't [ __ ] with me they
don't [ __ ] with you I'm coming to do a
show in your city where you live you
don't in your promoter and you don't
know 300 people how you promoted in you
can't bring 200 people to a club 300
people you the promoter half of the club
posted beat your people promoter the
other half is you posed to be an art we
come out how to add another show cuz cuz
I promoted this [ __ ] well man you ain't
did [ __ ] is the game is ugly man people
is a lot of people still in man and
that's what why a lot of people walking
around bitter and anger cuz it's too
many hands and the pot and people
playing this sympathy
acting like they don't have it and then
they stealing from you stealing only
every money oh every level you getting
robbed at the comedy club you can rob
that the network you can rob doing all
of that [ __ ] bro they it's not even that
it's like some of these people that you
go do these shows and you know [ __ ] for
it's like these people who you know like
these corporations and networks you know
it's super rich is [ __ ] and it's like
you work with them
it's like they just have a problem with
paying you like they have a personal
vendetta against seeing you have
happiness in life or some [ __ ] like they
just like not we know him only give him
this money like what the [ __ ] did he
negotiated you have to negotiate yeah
that's the game to negotiation is a
whole nother part of the game
that's why you need agents and managers
and [ __ ]
people believe your [ __ ] more when other
people are speaking on your behalf
because if you had to sit there back and
forth and tell these people what she was
worth and why you need this money you're
gonna get frustrated and black [ __ ] this
[ __ ] I gotta tell you you I gotta tell
you why I need this money if you give my
[ __ ] roof collapse right and I call
the roof dude he said well it's gonna be
$3500 to put a new roof on this [ __ ]
he's not about to say I'm spending
exactly $39 on nails
I gotta hire this dude who I'm paying
1750 he's not about to break that [ __ ]
down bro do you want this [ __ ] or naw
cuz we on to the next one
somebody calling me right now bro we
need to if you're trying to [ __ ] with
this [ __ ] [ __ ] with it but all that
other [ __ ] leave me out of it man what
is it like in those rooms where I feel
like at this point like with with the
following you have and the influence you
have it seems like you would have the
leverage in no situation right they'll
still tell you that it's not enough if
you got 1 million followers you need to
5 I've got 5 you need 10 whatever it is
that you have just know that you only
half way there be the most talented
[ __ ] in the world but they'll
tell you you can't read music alright
you know I'm saying you don't [ __ ]
need to read music to do the [ __ ] that
you do you dude I'm saying yeah
everything don't apply to everybody I
think that's what 85 South is all about
is you guys doing it your way let's see
the 85 self show is us saying oh y'all
don't wanna [ __ ] with it I will [ __ ]
with we'll do it i sell-- yeah cuz we
know that we an act we own the road we
know what people want we know what they
need that this ain't that even if they
put if you put us on your network and
your TV show they still need this you
get home saying this is the part that
they [ __ ] with because they seen us
come up and rise as comedians and be on
television and be on different shows and
add those notches and you know stripes
to our comedic accolades so they know
what the rise is they seen DC on
Instagram vine and all that they know
that the grand pays off and you get to
get bigger and bigger and bigger but at
some point they like what you doing we
see you every night on CSI but what you
doing though what you know saying what
you talking about we know that you ain't
getting to say to [ __ ] that you want to
say so what are you what do you have to
say they don't have to be [ __ ] five
DHD red camera now I want to see that
cameraphone [ __ ] somebody record that
they smoking a blunt what they talking
about
I guess that [ __ ] that you can't get
nowhere else it's all that authenticity
right because that's what makes people
[ __ ] with you they need to see that you
a real [ __ ] like you like them
uh-huh it's the realness how real that
what type of blessed is [ __ ] smoking is
that good is that buy so is everybody
connects with you for different [ __ ] you
might make a fan because you did that
one clean joke well that one [ __ ] joke
made that old man buy a ticket to see
you again
all these white dudes who who was
trippin on some mushrooms one night and
watched your [ __ ] for 12 hours straight
and now they really [ __ ] with you like
you won't you know I'm saying yeah you
never know how people get attracted to
you or what makes people buy tickets to
come see you specifically or it's pde
inviting you up to the office
it could small stuff like that you never
know who's sitting back watching these
episodes man it's crazy yeah did he been
watching [ __ ] from 40 episodes it was on
the trap house he liked the trap he's
like the trap house episode it was like
man how long you been watching this year
and what episode made you say I call
them [ __ ] yeah the [ __ ] moment was
then because I want to know that moment
so I gotta have some more than [ __ ] did
you ask him hell yeah
what'd he say I asked him man I asked
Diddy all types of [ __ ] what you learn
from him I learned that this dude has a
wide scope you know like the big fish in
that [ __ ] this dude has a
why scope of everything that's going on
not because somebody said hey dare to
check this out because he actually
physically gets in that bitchin and
listen and goes on to YouTube and and
finds the new [ __ ] and vibe with that
[ __ ] like a real fan he's still a fan of
everything he's very aware who he is
and he understands the game and what's
what's gonna be to the game changes
before they're even the game he'll I
could see that [ __ ] that is very inkling
you knows like that's the [ __ ] that
changed the game and he'd be passionate
about the [ __ ] like his real [ __ ]
already you know that's what I picked up
that's the vibe that and he's really not
just the month like we're so used to
seeing Diddy the you know the character
but then you sit there like this is real
Lance do like you know I'm saying like
you would never know that he's not
yelling poor in Ciroc everywhere you
would think that and that's what you
would want to happen if you think that
that [ __ ] is funny now until you and
that's why I was like bro we got to
drink some survived with Diddy yeah he
said that yeah but you were definitely
like if he came out and he was doing
that [ __ ] if it was a big daily
production and he came out with you be
like yeah yeah can't disappoint me I
know he was this [ __ ]
but then he come out again his Sean John
hey what's up guys you know whatever TC
like that time he's like oh man you
never know what did is going show yeah
yeah so Sean John showed up bro we got
to speak to Sean John Diddy P Diddy
puffy I asked him if I can still call
him puffy told me it was cool cuz that
was like all the rap [ __ ] the whole rap
[ __ ] that I came up with like big smiles
and like Missy used to throw puffy name
in a lot of her songs oh yeah she had
the famous Lam Puff Daddy be my pal and
she said that in like seven song I
always wondered why was Nicki I mean why
was Missy and Biddy such good friends I
never saw the connection but she threw
that in a lot of songs burn yeah man I
had a ball he asked him about that
infamous land when he said I got a Benz
that I ain't even drove yet he said he
still ain't drove
kidding me I'm not bright he said he
still ain't drove man that's game right
there is broad that is crazy
yeah what on the actual why did he guys
up like what was the reason he loves
this show bro he loves the show you want
to work with you like what yeah he
really [ __ ] with what we got going on
he sees that we build an organic
following and we giving them raw real
content every look different looks you
know I'm saying and he just sees that we
could really do something big what we
had for what he like he have a vision
just thinking of it being on revolt or
even just trying to be like this is what
the potential could be even it was just
even bigger than that he was like even
if it's not revolt
right just know that this is this is the
new [ __ ] this is a wave in comedy not
because not just saying that this is
comedy this is a different this is a
different perspective that we're not
getting nowhere else like it's it's not
super flashy rapper it's not playing
bling in your face
it's the joys the pains the ups and
downs the the grind of chasing the
entertainment dream you know I'm saying
yeah yeah yeah you guys are actually
capturing that right in the main and
from the jump like from this was kind of
started at the bottom now we're here and
you're just now getting started
yeah is like I said this past Sunday at
that you brought up the House of Blues
it's it's just a dope ass intro like all
these all the years of just putting in
work I always feel like it's still the
first day still every time I pursue
anything whether it be an episode of wow
there now or movie audition or just some
filming some TV work
I would like that's what the part of
comedy that I just never got over every
time I get that get a call for a show
I'm still excited I still you know I
mean all that [ __ ] what do you think
seeing the path you're going on right
now and the mistakes you've made and the
people you've surround your
self with what are some things comedians
can do to really take their career into
their own hands um this sounds crazy but
you I call this [ __ ] like the Soulja Boy
method it's like but a lot of like I
guess a good street transit I like
terminology it would be to fake it till
you make it not even necessarily saying
be a fake person but you gotta start
building the [ __ ] that you want before
somebody else comes and validates you
you don't saying like investing yourself
and that [ __ ] sound corny but it it'll
it'll pay off in the long run cuz you're
just getting a habit of doing business
comedians nowadays well the difference
that I see from when I was first
starting and comedians now is they don't
take themselves seriously like comedians
did even when we were six months eight
months a year into the game you know I'm
saying even the dude who wasn't the
funniest comedian around still knew how
to go manipulate a headshot or
manipulate some business cars or burn a
DVD have a CD just something to show my
[ __ ] that you was here to stay you
know I'm saying that's the difference
our followers as important as people are
playing them up to be right now what if
you had a bunch of followers that didn't
like you why would they follow you to
tell you every day that they don't like
to tell you that everything you believe
in is [ __ ] terrible that they hate
all of your career everything you've
ever done you created they ain't it and
they hope you don't make it and they
just come to your page and check to make
sure you ain't made it it that almost
seems to be the chase right now though
is everybody's worried about followers
instead of ala t you see people all the
time we have a million followers right
and just say that cuz that's the
benchmark right then you look at some
[ __ ] that they post and that [ __ ] get
5,000 likes but then you see the girl
with the fat ass who got eight
and follows every picture that she posts
get 34 thousand likes and 22,000 count
you know which position would you rather
be in would you rather have a a lot of
people that don't [ __ ] with you or a
handful of people didn't support the
[ __ ] out of everything you do either way
I don't want my ass out yeah I can see
why I see why you I mean every because
that's the thing about man we couldn't
if we wanted some attention you couldn't
just post your dick print but I got away
you are is not you're not like attract
the type of women that you would want to
see it it would be a bunch of fat
[ __ ] and women named Tanya they work
at the Waffle House yeah come get some
[ __ ] like look so I'm like you've been
having people slide through the DM I'm
just saying
dude you don't matter how [ __ ]
attractive and sexy you think you are if
you go on that bitching post and pitch
it's not gonna attract the type of women
that you want to see that [ __ ] just
don't work like that for but it you
could even be metaphorically and having
your ass out can mean you post like is
just just asking for attention yeah you
can tell you can see the desperation in
a lot of people's and hansbrough social
media made a lot of people famous that
don't do [ __ ] it was the the dislike
that made people like everything there's
a lot of [ __ ] who just people
go see what the [ __ ] they're doing
because they're doing some stupid [ __ ]
just to be like look at this stupid [ __ ]
look at this dumb and this [ __ ] is not
funny
look at your boy that's what I'm saying
man Haden somebody found a way to
reverse the hate with online [ __ ] in
social media yeah found a whole way to
flip the skirt so even the more you
dislike some [ __ ] the further it goes
because when you don't like some [ __ ]
you tell everybody when you do like some
[ __ ] you don't even want to like it you
know leave a comment hate can spread
just as far as love that's why I posted
that [ __ ] yesterday brands not the truth
that we looking for us the last that
keep us happy social media you gotta be
careful with this [ __ ] oh you've done a
lot of you go to like India oh no what
is all this wisdom but I'm just saying
the followers are important it's like
yeah it's important if that's if you in
the strain you're doing something with
him but it's got a bunch of followers
that watch you do [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are
you doing you not get no money on there
right that's the safe in encouragement
because then you get these father's than
they like you and then you think did you
somebody right and then you post a
picture of your mom on Mother's Day and
they roast your mom they talk about your
son like my shoes dirty yeah yeah I saw
a video of you you were like walking in
the mall and this car just rolls up on
you and starts roasting here I thought
those dudes you gonna jump out that
[ __ ] with ak-47 ar-15 these they want
to play and [ __ ] and it's definitely not
the time to be playing no like whoa man
ouch [ __ ] I got it does that happen a
lot and you never know what you'd never
know you can't do [ __ ] people always
peeping and watching you never know
who's lurking so you always got to stay
sharp man you've been in some scary
situations I don't get scared of [ __ ]
like that though the most terrifying
situations that I have escaped they
weren't scary I guess cuz your body just
your mind is going through another mode
or some [ __ ] but like the scariest [ __ ]
that I've ever been through in my life
wasn't even scary going through it it's
after the fact when you sit back and you
look at what could have happened that
you start overthinking and [ __ ] like oh
[ __ ] stop being prepared for over
preparing for the next time or whatever
whatever what was that you just man is
there's a lot of situations where you
end up in rooms wouldn't full of people
with [ __ ] you don't know and
you wait a [ __ ] over there and there's
one door out and you start just lying
let me get the [ __ ] out of here before
at that time because some kind of way
the people that I was with have wandered
off and I'm I don't know what the [ __ ] I
am
you know no nothing's people on these
[ __ ] extra-friendly and I guess
it's too quiet in here there's too many
[ __ ] looking at me Kevin
recently I'm sure it happened all the
time when I just have to realize what a
[ __ ] you are and be aware your
surroundings you just wandering around
some city Ewing familiar with you ain't
in this [ __ ] following you right
you know I'm saying you don't you not
even paying attention to this car that
then loop by and saw you and went down
and turned around and people you know
I'm saying you just make you you just
have to be extra alert cuz you never
know who knows you and what they see you
as you tour although around the world
now you kind of have more of a global
perspective on the world which may be
informing but this the thing Dogra
people people can see who you really are
they know who that I'm not saying that
everybody don't have the number call but
it's a it's a certain way that you carry
yourself to let [ __ ] know that
you might be with that [ __ ] too you
might rob me I might blow your [ __ ]
head off you don't they can see the pain
in your eyes or where you come from or
what you what you made of the way you
carry yourself you know I'm saying this
[ __ ] might or might wanted to
rob you at the gas station but he's
saying you carry yourself in a certain
way or you see heard you say something
that be like I that's one of us you get
what I'm saying mmm it's dark
it took a dark turn but it's not
necessarily even the dark use I'm
talking about awesome
yeah like you out in the street [ __ ] but
just the same when you're going to talk
to these [ __ ] agents and and managers
and [ __ ] they can promise you the world
they don't rob you with guns they rob
you with words and the papers and [ __ ]
that's some Jadakiss by the way they do
that it's not everybody's a [ __ ]
shark breath some [ __ ] get you
with the knife some get you with the
pain bro you got got like on the on the
pen yeah everybody is but that's part of
the game though knowing knowing your
work if you you don't never know what
these people made off of this [ __ ] you
just know what you agree to right right
what can I just to keep it maybe towards
comedians more because that's the world
where and it's like what are what are
some maybe red flags we can keep an eye
out for from mistakes or lessons you've
had to learn the red flags don't be out
here trusting people don't be believing
this [ __ ]
don't if it sounds good too good to be
true it is man mm-hmm you know I mean
nobody is out here looking for your best
interest and don't nobody give a [ __ ]
about your feelings Sony you learned
that [ __ ] the more you can the better
you can understand it the person you r
at your home it might be your dog you
might have anything bruh
but don't never think that somebody's
gonna do something for you just because
they [ __ ] with you nobody it's all it's
all the business man and you can see you
start to see it once you get start
working it like business they don't give
a [ __ ] about who you think is funny or
whatever they gonna put whoever on this
show because that's what they doing is
their club they hired you but they had
these other [ __ ] - oh what
other business advice could you share
I got seen invest in yourself and find
and find another way find more than one
way to get paid don't just think don't
just get paid off telling jokes because
people steal jokes all the time mm-hmm
and the people not gonna check to see
who wrote it they don't give a [ __ ]
they just know who excuse me they just
laughed at it because that's what was
available at the time thank you oh [ __ ]
who it came from
well how old is showcase none of that
just get your money and don't never
worry about what somebody else doing you
might get you might get hired and be
doing the exact same [ __ ] and these
[ __ ] standing right beside you
got fired got paid five times more than
you just because they asked for and you
didn't they had the right infrastructure
set up they handle business they at the
right manager at the right agent and
they got what they asked for so that
plays a big part into it your team right
yeah you got a like you can't be
successful by yourself man
see now you're saying you gotta look out
for yourself but then you can't be
successful by yourself nobody gives
successful body sell huh don't know
believe it no wedding you start looking
around and paying attention to how
people get into the industry the the
industry industry there's always
somebody else who got him in there
somebody uncle was a producer or they
dad was a wrote a Motown song you know
saying you never know the connection is
you your name will get you a whole lot
further than your talent will your
reputation precedes you being funny is
just as best as one of the 10 things you
got to do to get just to be in the
conversation and you can't you can't
just be fly-by-night funny you got to be
consistently funny it's people who I at
the top of the game who want to [ __ ]
with you but I just want to see how you
handle the next three years see how you
develop and what kind of sense you have
in the next year so where you at can you
stay in there a lot of people come and
go
can you stay hot like getting hot is
easy cuz don't nobody know you you do
magic every night like where did he come
from right and then you get in that
position where it's like now you're
expected to create man are you really a
magician it's a great analogy yeah it's
the back like [ __ ] want to be
in that spot but then when you get in
that spot and you got to do that hour
and a half after everybody in the club
just came and did they best [ __ ] can you
do it are you made of that really made
of
it's the third show of the night you can
you do three a night that's what
headliners do can you come on stage and
say [ __ ] you I'm out here well you wear
your improv [ __ ] it are you off the cuff
or you can only tell jokes that you
wrote you might be a headliner but you
might what if you only got exactly one
hour of jokes to tell yeah word for word
how do you freestyle I like what is what
is the technique behind it cuz I'll try
sometimes but then if one thing misses I
may start to doubt and then I'll start
to work backwards but I've seen
potential in it but I you know I end up
tucking my tail and running
you can't do that bro when you're
telling jokes you don't wait for this
crowd to approve this [ __ ] it's funny
you tell the joke like you tell that
[ __ ] with the same conviction as you
tell your joke that you know as a banger
because it's not the joke best one is
you you got to be a funny person that's
why I always wonder how some people made
it to you know this long because they're
not funny people they're not funny at
school ain't that funny at work they
weren't funny growing up they never make
nobody they never made me laugh and all
these years I've known them like what is
it that you're doing how are you
substantive yeah yeah yeah who is
booking this [ __ ] how do they
have a demand maybe they have a good
team exactly you good
some people do so it's how you say your
joke it's cuz you can get a lot caught
up in that right that's what I'm saying
bro you have to detach yourself from I'm
a comedian here's a joke
that's so cookie cutter it's not being a
comedian it's not the joke comedians
make [ __ ] funny the [ __ ] don't you don't
mean you don't and making something
funny doesn't mean going onstage a bunch
of times and saying that [ __ ] and trying
to figure out to make it funny like a
comedian is the type of person who can
be going into an audition and might say
to say one word one word wrong 50 times
but it's funny every time they [ __ ] up
that's a comedian now our comic can sit
at home all day write jokes and flip
channels and do little interpretations
of what this comedian said a little word
flip in there but that's all prepared
[ __ ] they do their impression of a
comedian they put all black on it little
goofy hands hat and want to tell jokes
were when Mike's standing a stool cuz
that's what they're the essence of
comedy but they're not funny people you
know some people just don't have that
natural spark they can deliver a joke or
they can say some [ __ ] somebody wrote
for him but they not funny people so
it's different skill sets
maybe some a better joke writer and not
as good improviser right that's just
like saying you just I'll use
instruments all the time friends just
like saying you a dope-ass trumpet
player but you can only play a song if
you got the music you don't really know
how to play that [ __ ] you don't
really know how to play that [ __ ] if you
you know I'm saying you see people play
basketball some [ __ ] are great
basketball players and they're good like
any other to any other court you put
them on they're [ __ ] amazing but then
you put them on court with LeBron and
[ __ ] Steph Curry and KD and they look
like children giving them saying they're
not built for that they body really
physically not built for that bro he's
like you just not made for this [ __ ]
you're the best point guard in the
league but you can never be a [ __ ]
small forward you'll never be a sinner
but then it's some [ __ ] who you
can put them on the court and you don't
even have to tell him what to do some
there's some people just naturally
gifted bo Jackson's Deion Sanders the
[ __ ] you know I'm saying
the challenge is [ __ ] proceed to
Odell Beckham's they could do any
[ __ ] thing birth and it just any good
at it if they not good at it they're at
least good enough at it to captivate you
and make you watch them not be good at
it so you got to have the self belief
too man let's kind of play into it that
confidence seems the longer I've been
doing comedy you know I've been doing it
over eight years now and it seems like
confidence can really drive the audience
response yeah man if you can make people
like you don't matter what you say cuz
they like you they want you to think
when people like you they treat you
different because you give them
something and you give them a feeling
it's happiness if you can make people
happy [ __ ] what you do [ __ ] the jokes
that you told they'll come see you a
hundred times because you make them
happy
its atmosphere hmm you acknowledge them
you talk to people different that's the
part about that's the part when you can
keep find out what makes people like you
that's what I make you a star that's
what Kevin Hart is winning so hard right
now he found out how to make people like
him he's a lack of would be
want to see him win you celebrate his
victories with him because they make you
feel like you're a part of them so find
out what people like about you right it
might not necessarily be the jokes it
might be your stupid Anna's pants your
boyish grin or your voice it just might
like you cuz you were tall [ __ ]
but it might like you cuz you're a
pretty fat [ __ ]
you're just a flat person you smell good
you carry yourself different you got a
different swag your delivery you got an
accent from where you from they don't go
back to you though man what you kind of
find like this is my best advice find a
highlighter and use it on yourself like
if you a woman with some big-ass titties
let people know you know you got them
[ __ ] so you got big brown eyes or
whatever for holidays are your weapons
if you could sing if you can do an
impression you can sound just like a
[ __ ] these are all talents you
bring to the stage cuz they gonna get
that [ __ ] from you boom and you have a
lot of different talents man how are you
planning on using these going forward
that's the part about having them you
don't know what the talented people
don't even know that they talented a lot
of 90% of the time every every artist
that you know that's not a that's not on
that level like I bet you know somebody
right now that's probably the dopest art
as you've ever met can draw anything
just sitting there [ __ ] around but
anytime you see it by man that's the
dopest [ __ ] I ever seen and I'll tell
you everything that's wrong with this
[ __ ] I'm not finished
I [ __ ] up on the eyes I can't draw
feet I smudged some paint like you'll
never see that [ __ ] so you will never
know how good you are they ever like
nobody like it's month [ __ ]
don't know they great they just know
that they out there doing some other
[ __ ] is that a common trait you've
noticed cuz I mean you've I'm sure
you've been around the 1% of the 1% and
in this just like sometimes you meet
people and you can tell them like as
artists or some [ __ ] and they made a
major favorite song you tell them that
[ __ ] they're like yeah ok cool think and
you did some [ __ ] that changed your life
right what I'm saying right yeah all
right cool I mean you know what song got
really
love all you [ __ ] with that one cool you
give them saying his life play it cool
they probably heard every day though
yeah but that's what I'm saying but they
never heard your interpretation of so is
you know never you never will see your
own greatness until you've probably done
and all the last man going back through
the highlights and you don't recognize
that [ __ ] because you're in the moment
cuz you just want a [ __ ] ice cold war
but if you're not if you didn't get to
play the part that you wanted to play
you just still don't be in pursuit of
that right there's always something else
right so what else is there for you man
I ain't even done [ __ ] yet
oh I haven't done [ __ ] yet man nothing
nothing at all but that's the thing I
don't I think that a lot of the [ __ ]
that I want to do or I'll end up doing
you know with the right with the right
amount of hustle and termination and
blessings it'll be something totally
totally obscure from telling jokes
because I'm one of my goals is to just
get on one of those shows are getting
one of those spaces that you would never
imagine seeing me
you owe me I'd be the first black dude
to be the Joker's I'm [ __ ] you know I
mean that's the type of [ __ ] I be aiming
for tonight I'm going to kill the Batman
like see I'm dumb well I can see that
I'm awesome [ __ ] man I can see that yeah
Wow
we broke into Carlos area we saw a
couple Carlos moments right now you're
like lohse whoa straight straight I
didn't know man I didn't know we were
talking [ __ ] you ask me all these
questions that required like real
answers and [ __ ] well I mean well you
knew coming in that you started the
interview in that mode cuz you knew what
this was right so we captured it man
it's kind of captured its captured man
before we get out of here is there
anything else you want the world to know
um a man this the [ __ ] I've been on
anything is true of you believe it okay
anything is true if you believe that
[ __ ] so be careful what you out here
believing subscribe to some of your own
[ __ ] man what do you believe I
believe I'm a magnificent [ __ ]
every day and every day shall be full of
surprises
well I got a say man after you coming
straight off the road and this is kind
of your transition day you're doing
shows all weekend at uptown comedy Kona
and the fact you were willing to do this
man
Joe I like your hustle man you always on
you stay persistent you stay grinding
and you just refuse to lose bro that's
the whole mindset like you were doing a
whole one-man show but you get what I'm
saying like you do all this [ __ ]
yourself that's the grime that's the
grind just stay on that [ __ ] stay
posting your [ __ ] somebody in the
comments [ __ ] with you [ __ ] so hard
they want to be a part of what you're
doing they want to over the camera I
wanna be in the room they wanna ride
with you the starts to end people just
volunteer to [ __ ] with you when they see
that you when you got that mindset that
you got that refusal ooh [ __ ] yeah that
draws people to you and then make them
want to help you win that's why you
shouldn't be afraid to ask for what you
want put it out there a lot of times as
entertainers we get put into a box where
we get afraid to ask for things don't be
afraid to ask people to help you that's
another one and let people do what they
do bro let the camera man be the camera
man let the sound dude be the sound dude
let people be who let them be with a
Opera don't nobody like to be ran find
somebody you believe in that you don't
have the tail to do the [ __ ] because
they see it like you see it yeah I found
a lot of those connections also happen
organically that's what it is kind of
they just kind of flow into your life
and you just kind of hop on the raft
together you have to cuz you know the
saying is if you want to go fast go
alone you want to go far take your
friends carlos Miller yep my man I've
been reading in shape I told you I was
gonna [ __ ] their minds up yeah I wasn't
ready for that
I know let me know we're just gonna be a
man how's it been going you like you
listen to me man
we write in a book water is wet in the
Eagles attract what the [ __ ] is he
saying I might have been rambling but I
just I had to share that [ __ ] with your
art I know you got some audience out
there but that's what I let them know
it's what it's all about Joe is brick by
brick bro yeah bring that brick and I
had gone through a little bit of
self-doubt over like the past week or so
but this is this is definitely I've had
a good moment this is all self-doubt
just don't never doubt yourself take all
the negative [ __ ] ever if you just tell
yourself I'm the [ __ ] every day and
don't don't accept nothing else it's all
Jeezy line and say I'm the [ __ ] and if I
ain't y'all let me think what I think I
don't change my mind about me being the
[ __ ] mm-hmm laugh at your problems
handle them but don't ever let them
[ __ ] handle you
I don't ever be up stressing about some
[ __ ] you either can do it or you can't
why would you kill yourself worrying
about some [ __ ] that you can't change
you just got to figure out what the [ __ ]
you can do man and that skills and what
your what people like about you and then
just go with that the whole way yeah
that's your money anything that you can
do better than everybody else cashing in
on it if you had a job right now that
you [ __ ] hate and you know that you
got the best hand right in there [ __ ]
bro find a way to write some letters do
something I'm just saying man it might
be ten dollars a weekend but I'm telling
you you can capitalize off anything that
you better than everybody else that and
there's room for everyone it is room for
everyone bro
everybody even the dopest [ __ ]
is looking for an assistant to be the
second dopest [ __ ] yeah
yo Z like there's no [ __ ] in the game
bro
Drake is Drake right but look what he
did when he jumped on the meego trick
he brought the me goes to the forefront
and they never left because they was
dope it was like no I'm dope but this is
dope to me so I'm gonna validate but
though even if this does nothing i [ __ ]
with this because because I [ __ ] with
this yeah cuz some people go up like a
bottle rocket yeah it's just like like
you said cuz
they weren't actually they weren't real
sometimes your blessing is to be the
blessing breath you might not be the
rapper that's gonna blow up and be the
next little Wayne but you might be the
person who gave them the opportunity to
be the next little Wayne you might find
the next one that whole two part [ __ ]
you will be the mind that sparked the
change that changed the game just
because you use what you have and you
open the gift [ __ ] up to somebody else
your own then share that [ __ ] find the
dopest get around it Frank get around
people that inspire you
the regalo goes back to your team what
you put you around the most that's what
you're gonna that's what you're attract
if you around a whole bunch of dope
[ __ ] sheet of cold his model he
Dakota's photographer your homeboys the
dopest director to you and you see how
good they are like respect the creatives
that don't have to be that's not already
on their level see that [ __ ] believe in
other people too because that's how you
grow your talent your blessing yeah I
heard he's erase a like everybody wants
to reach up and try to work with people
that are there
reach across exactly reach across broom
you'd be surprised how you run back into
that dude who telling you the PA dude
who just go get the coffee and make sure
everybody get in the car five years he
pulling up as his production he the
director or he the producer or he the EP
or he was he had enough juice to say
ain't call my man Carlos Miller be
perfect for this year I'm saying like
you never know what people can [ __ ]
do for you in the future just by
cultivating and establishing real
relationships not because you want
something just because they reaching
across and guild openness validates
their doughnuts they help these people
find you so now these people want to
give them a permanent you know saying
mmm-hmm is to look out without looking
sometimes told me a no-look pass that's
it Carlos Miller thanks for being on hot
breath my man my man and I'm in saying
this is a you can keep this water this
a gift free man is that all fan art you
know that's so dope have fans send you
art they send all pulling up on you and
roasting you yeah is that all fan stuff
over there
what yo that's sick
it's a mug with your face on it yeah and
it looks like legit like you though like
quality art what's his name yeah that's
crazy dude a bunch of Instagram stuff
people have connected with Matt sick
dude that's how that's how I got this
water was to Instagram it was like the
company's called fonta sand they're
based in Georgia because they have like
a spring in the Blue Spring Mountains
and I was like hey you do custom labels
we should collaborate and boom now we
got hot breath water
we out you dude I appreciate the words
of encouragement I hope everybody out
there listening today learned a lot and
found wisdom and I gave you game [ __ ]
brah people come on and be funny they
try to do they do a lot of jokes and
[ __ ] on here this is more like behind
like with when I even when I interviewed
Chad he's like man I don't have much to
say and then I was like well once we got
into the machine of 85 South and he's
like well we did come from here and
nothing isn't on accident and have you
know like people that came from working
with Steve Harvey and like right know
the production side of 85 south I knew
the execution was at such a high level I
was like I need to talk to producer of
this and figure out
what is going on here right he didn't
drop all the sauce he was hesitant on
some things but I mean I'm just saying
like seeing that operation and thinking
of your team and who you surround
yourself with that is a well-oiled
machine that is winning for a reason and
it's and why P Diddy is just reaching
out and like yo you're onto something
right because it's not it hadn't even
started like you said it's just the dope
as interim we're gonna keep pushing bro
yeah definitely gonna keep pushing
because the way that the Fate the
feedback in the you know the comments
and [ __ ] of what people have given back
to us from what we created is just been
phenomenal man like sold-out shows all
over the place sold out the House of
Blues man and it's just like on some
comedian [ __ ] and you look at the
wall they only let you sign the wall if
you sell out the show and you look at
the names bronies like the biggest
entertainers that you know these are
dope musicians with platinum records in
all types of superstar burr and you
don't know why right there with them
yeah cuz we actually sold out the show
bro it's crazy congratulations thank you
bro thank you for your time I'll let you
lay down and rest up for your shows this
weekend but this has been real most
definitely y'all keep supporting Joe
Biden the hot brother podcast your
stinking awards your funky horse your
horse all of you we out here
yes boichiro yeah I gotta get him on
here
you